[Music]
so today I'm going to tell you a couple
stories I like telling stories and it's
going to be details of a couple machine
learning projects that we've done with
my team admission for our two customers
and we was talking publicly about this
so one of the customers is the tech
resources one of the largest mining
company in the world and the largest in
Canada this is the machine that we've
been working on predicting when they
actually going to fail that's me and
Paul down there they're so big pole
sitting right there he's so small so you
can see the proportions right and
another project I'm going to talk about
is how we're analyzing the cricket match
videos to extract certain information
out of them so a completely different
you know machine learning applications
but there's many common themes that
you're going to go through and I think
you're gonna take quite a few insights
out of those and of course we build
those on on GCP so and if something
doesn't work they apologize this
presentation styles little new we've
done it before once so it kind of works
so I think I'll be cool so a little bit
about pitten pitten is 20 years old
company we help customers to innovate
with data and with the cloud
specifically our machine learning
practice is helping build real-world AI
solutions and that couple of those we're
going to look at today including some
details one of those projects actually
the one for the ECB we submitted for the
partner of the Year award and it was
selected so yesterday we actually got a
partner of the Year award in data
analytics so that's one else we've been
on the stage receiving it a little bit
about me
hi I'm Alex I'm a cloud feature today
I've been a patient for 13 years been
doing a lot of different things from you
know running a team of database
engineers to creating a new business and
in your region and today I'm a cloud
secure as well as run our machine
learning practice so ambition is you
know very known from to your partner of
Google we have four specializations and
the world of cloud migrations health
customer build data systems and
ái solutions in them in a Google cloud
all right so a little bit about tech so
tech is as I mentioned already Canada's
largest diversified to source company
it's a fashionable way to say mining
company and they're very modern very
modern and all of those devices are
equipment in the mines actually a big
IOT devices today so specifically what
we're going to focus on is on those
babies this is a Komatsu nine-30 II
holding trucks and it's about 1 million
[Music]
dollars truck right so it's a it's quite
big it's quite because you've seen on a
picture so basically what we're going to
look today is that we're going to look
at the how can we predict the failure of
those machines because cost of failure
is actually quite large a single failure
electrical subsistence fail and we
focused on that today actually cost
anywhere between a hundred thousand to
several million to six and the cost
comes from two things one of them is a
cost of repair like a direct repair and
the early we can support the potential
problem and initiate the repair the less
usually this repair cost
but the biggest costs actually crime
comes from being the truck being idle
because I mean resource constrained
environment when the truck doesn't hold
coal or doesn't hold stone rock we don't
get any any revenue right so that's
where the biggest are the biggest cost
coming from so predicting fail allows us
to do this maintenance and repair at a
time when we're not resource constrained
so we reduce or eliminate this idling
cost right
so again what do we need we need an
early warning right we need an early
warning and ideally we want to know how
much time until the truck gonna fail
right that would be our Nirvana or
depending on some other types of failure
we want to know a level of
underperformance how deteriorated the
resource or a component is so we can
decide which ones we take for the
proactive maintenance sauce so they
estimated that if you can predict
electrical or high voltage electrical
subsystem failures then they could save
up to four million a year just with this
failure alone right and
coping on a three mining site with 108
trucks like this so now we have a kind
of problem and we have a need and we
always tried to be very disciplined and
establishing those sauce before we're
moving towards machine learning
solutions because it allows us to have a
full circle and estimate you know our Y
of our work as well
now what's the date we're working with
so this is several you know data set
inputs that we're going to work with
data sets we're going to work with but
one of them is that hey where do we get
predictive data in order to support the
things in order to support the patterns
that indicate a pending failure right so
those are trucks equipped with sensors
that you know send the readings as a you
know time series data as well as alerts
and events which are generated on those
trucks from you know actuators from the
the smart systems embedded in those as
well this time dispatch date has some
other data sources available as well but
all tonight we're going to work only
with the time series data are here and
the each truck generates about two
gigabytes of data per day and you know
hundreds of thousand data points per
track per second approximately now so
obviously this is where our big data
coming from right we've been working
with the four years of historical data
available today three mining sites more
than a hundred trucks millions of alerts
billions of sensor reading and it
definitely must be a machine learning
problem right we have a large enough
data set but you know what do we do with
this before I go through that what to
enough take a step back and share with
you our learning that over the years of
you know building AI solutions we've
always tried to narrow down our problem
as a supervised learning problem right
because it allows us to measure how well
we're doing historically it allows us to
give convincing a convincing insight to
end-user it's a very actionable result
as opposed to things like and another
detection when you say something seems
wrong with this truck and so what is it
thousands of components on this truck
right or you know try to create some
clustering can figure out certain
patterns sooner there's so many patterns
but most of them have nothing to do with
electrical failures that you're going to
look at right so
result we always try to narrow down the
problem in some way and state it as a
supervised learning problem when we
don't have unknown actionable outcomes
that we can you know predict with the
model whether it's a classification or
regression type of problem right now
where do we get the labels well there
are maintenance historical maintenance
date and the historical database of the
spare part and so on the trouble is that
some of this data is not actually been
digitized so this is where their analyst
their maintenance analyst had to go back
for a few years go through all the data
and actually extract some of the failure
and predictive or preventive repair
information and suppliers are those now
we've had so much data it's great but
what about those fellows themselves well
this is where small data comes in and a
small data in this case we have only
really few dozen failure bins right
there was 31 catastrophic high voltage
failures of those 108 trucks or at least
31 that they could find and you know a
few dozen events that are resulting in
suspension exchanges or recharges
so-called when it's deteriorating and
then pump it up so it works a little
longer and most of those actually went
undocumented at all so as a result this
is the most important data that we
normally take into our projects and this
is the days that seem to have the lowest
quality right so we've had less
certainty
less certainty we have not as much
certainty that some events are not
missing from there right so we have to
be very careful how we use that how we
use that now does it smell like a
machine learning problem still when we
only work with a dozens of events so
it's very hard to build the model on
thirty events or so right so what do we
do well in general like as we move
forward as we have you know a business
need as we understood in our you know
data at least a little bit we need to
frame the problem as I said usually we
always try to narrow down on a
supervised learning which is as a
regression and classification then we
need to understand how to produce
reliable labels if they're not available
right modeling techniques to use and you
know
in the future engineering so a general
kind of directions that we that we're
following now let's say what we want to
predict is let's start with an obvious
we just want to predict time to failure
this would be great we know exactly when
according to the model the resource is
gonna fail component gonna fail but it's
really hard to build that right because
there's very few samples and other than
just training the model to find out
whether some weather failure is gonna
happen or not we now need to distinguish
was it going to happen one day from now
seven days from now or 20 days from now
which is significantly harder problem to
do and there's some phenotypes actually
not devoting and progressive fashion at
all right so we won't be able even to
say whether it's one day or seven days
so as a result we had to kind of go back
and look at the problem again and what
we normally do we always try to look at
the problem from the eyes of their human
who already doing the work today ideally
if that's possible now in this case as
it helps supervisors what they do is
that many times a day they look at their
dashboard some kind of heuristic rules
and so on and make a guess I think this
thing gonna fail
I'll need to take sort of maintenance
but what they do ultimately they take
observations and make some kind of
conclusions using whatever human insight
and their knowledge that they have right
so that teaches us two things it's great
that we can now have those observations
many times a day it's much more than
just thirty failures we need to work
with but we don't have those
observations historically the good news
is we can simulate them from the failure
events that we have and I'll show how we
do that and another thing that we
learned is that it's actually not really
important to know exactly when the fail
are going to happen it's enough to say
that it's going to happen soon
soon enough and we've been sued enough
it's usually for them used to be a few
days right you know deign advance may be
a little late but four days seven days
is awesome so that's what we learn now
how do you reframe this problem so and
this is a you know one of them may be
most kind of innovative approach the
most creative thing we've done during
the
during this project so we basically
transform our events that we have from
the maintenance analyst that they
provided us into certain observations or
how do we do that so this is a let me
make sure all right so this is a
timeline right for each truck and
there's some trucks I said no failures
at all so this timeline would be clean
without events this is the failure end
this is a maintenance event when staff
decided to took the track out and
because they saw there what there would
be a problem and they fixed it but all
of those is indicating for us that this
is something wrong so we can do we work
with them in order to say all time in
the you know lifetime of a truck we're
gonna split in a certain ranges the
range before the failure of a certain
length we're going to cause a failure
pending rate or the failure range or a
bad range this is where we're going to
make observations every day a few times
a day and these observations will be
labeled as one which in our case meaning
a failure pending within this period of
time however long it is seven days ten I
think we ended up with the seven days in
the end now there's also some period of
time when there may be still a signal
because you know the the failure may
develop early but maybe not so it's kind
of a area when there's uncertainty in
the data if you're not sure whether
there's a strong signal or not so we
decided to mark those those ranges and
exclude them from taking observation so
we have a much cleaner delineation
between is a failure pending soon and
there's a clean zone when we don't
expect failure for example over the next
month or so right so as a result we
basically have those clean ranges met
marked as other green and then the red
ranges marked as failure pending and
sometime after the failure was fixed
because the way that we generating
labels of your labels our data features
you as we learned later we also excluded
from consideration right so what's
important here to remember is that
basically we simulated
observations right at the way the same
way they try to support the problem and
each of those point in time we kind of
make an observation and take the data we
know at that table but by that time from
our time series data and generate some
features that we're going to fit in the
model and model will basically be
trained on whether it's observations
from a clean range or from the failure
pending range that's it right so what
we've done is that we basically
interpolated dozens of rare events into
hundreds of thousands of observations
and you know thousands of observations
it's already something we can work with
and build the model on right although
still not a huge amount right so we have
to be quite careful now
so what do you do next you know an
obvious way of working this time series
data are you know as Paul will tell me
is like hey we built an RNN model it's
obviously designed to like get a
sequence of you know either of alerts
and sensor readings or some aggregators
of those and then you know make make a
prediction based on those but wind-up
was a huge feature space like tens of
thousands are points only for a few
thousand labels so we're going to end up
which is what's kind of known as the
dimensionality course when occurs when
we use a to complex feature space or to
complex model and we can obviously train
the model on those and it may show a
great a great result on training but on
the testing it it will not generalize
and the error will be huge and it will
basically definitely learn certain
patterns but there's so many patterns in
the data that will most likely learn
something else than electrical
electrical failures and it's definitely
what we've what we've seen so how do we
deal with this how do we deal with the
relatively few samples and a huge future
space well to fix that there's a few
things one of them we need to control
our model complexity and not go crazy
with creating complicated neural
networks for example and we also should
try to reduce our future space right
we already try to simplify the problem
by going away from a regression to a
binary classification that's as simple
as we can get so what do we do next now
in order to reduce the future space
we should be working more creatively on
the future engineering than just you
know see the sequence right so if you
want to employ some of the automated
kind of dimensionality reduction
techniques in this case it didn't quite
work because the data is not distributed
normally but what we did is that we work
with domain experts and you know
understood how we can embed you know a
temporal effect into our features made
from sensors and alerts without actually
having to work with a full sequence you
know of tens of thousands our data
points so what we've done is that it's
basically at each time that we make
observations we have this historical
data available up to that point so what
we've done is that we defined a several
like a sliding ranges of you know hours
or days and some of them even like
shifted back right and we create an
aggregate from those alerts and the
sensors and alerts the account of a
larger than those ranges what actually
the best in this case and the sizes of
those you know ranges as well as the
offset is what we actually been tuning
as part of the hyper parameter tuning so
we turn our feature engineering
parameters into kind of hyper parameters
as well right what we also been doing is
that when I was mentioning on how we
created those ranges the size of those
ranges we actually also made tunable so
our hyper parameter to make iterations
was not only on the model it was a
complete feature feature engineering
pipeline as well as a label production
pipeline right so that we can we can we
can tune that and understand what is
gonna work best when we have a four days
window a seven days window and how far
back we'll need to consider pushing this
clean clean range as well right if you
you know get more detailed questions
like you'll find me at the booth for the
rest of the day so he'll come up here
and we can talk about it now because we
taking our future engineering parameters
as well labeling parameters into as part
of our kind of tuning cycle or hybrid
parameters tuning cycle we need to be
careful how we you know do
- eternal training and testing right
what's important is that we need to
split in such a way that in the failure
event and the windows resulting from
failure from this trailer event will
ever be only in a training set or in a
in a testing set because otherwise
otherwise we we may cheat by basically
artificially tuning those labeling
windows and we may also introduce a
problem because a nearby observations
you know from today and from yesterday
will include data you know from the last
maybe 10 days or 15 days depending on
those ranges right so there may be very
similar so we need to make sure that we
don't you know use them in the training
and testing because it's kind of you
know cheating in this case right so we'd
be very careful that when we split the
day to actually split by events before
we start doing any transformations and
any tuning right so it very important
not to not too polluted in in this way
now also we had to take care of not
learning individual tracks because there
were some trucks actually most truck did
not have any failures we had a hundred
and eight trucks and 31 electrical
failures and some of the trucks failed
more than once right so as a result we
had to be careful and not to learn from
the those a huge amount of alerts and
sensors the patterns that attract
specific right so as a result we had to
you know include trucks obviously that
had no failures and pick up some of the
cleanup derivations from them right we
need to include trucks that never failed
in training but failed in testing set so
we'll cover those as well
so those things those are the things we
need to think about you know of course
when you know building models that
generalize as well also means that you
know we not just sporting a pattern
that's that's we're not interested in
which is you know actually learning the
truck or learning is a mining site for
example if it's end up that one side had
more failures and then then another now
how do the control model complexity well
if we stick to like an aural networks
and you'll just use highly regularized
not all networks but you know it's quite
a bit of effort and the good news is
that you know there's our algorithms
it's a very robust on this relatively
small data set was relatively
high number of features you know boosted
trees random forests we actually ended
up with a random forest model in the end
that worked really well for us that
worked really well for us and so that's
basically how we how we approach the
modeling techniques now something to
share is that what we've also done what
we also done is that we apply additional
smoothing on the output of the model so
in this case this is basically
observations this is time right this is
the model output which is basically we
can simplify it as probability of the
failure although it's slightly different
you know how you treat this after random
forest as an output but for the end
users that's the easiest way to present
it right and then and it's a little
spiky right as you see this is where the
failure happened in the past right so as
you can see the model actually some days
before started to produce the
probability of failure started to grow
right based on the model based on the
model but it was a little spiky so as a
result we decided to smooth it it's a
better user experience as well allows us
to remove some of the potential
noisiness from the from the model as
well and as you can see you know when
the failure was you know dealt with
dealt with the model prediction started
showing the lower probability as well
now how do we choose the threshold at
which we make a decision you know that
it's likely pending failure or not if we
choose it very high then we can miss the
events or miss the sailer or get
modifies very late for it if we choose
very low that we'll have too many you
know false positives and engineers will
constantly need to make a decision to
take the truck out so maintenance right
so knowing what's the average cost of
failure and knowing what the maintenance
what to check up costs we basically
could quickly build a formula that will
allow us to you know calculate how much
money we're going to save based on the
different threshold in here so it turned
out that the optimal optimal was around
this 0.5 now when we put it in
production
we've took into account another aspect a
human aspect of interpretation and a
human aspect is this those acid house
supervisors spent their life most of the
life doing this right and if we and
model ultimately will predict we'll make
some false positive will indicate a
failure when they won't be one happening
right so we want to make sure the very
beginning is that we give them
experience that will make them more
confident so the result would rather
miss some failures sometimes but make
sure that when they Cesar a lot when
they when they see the critical
condition they do react so the result we
choose a little bit higher and it will
be higher for them to be to be more
consonant in it and that worked actually
really really well although we did miss
some failures I'll go through the
results a little bit later now of course
we build at all in a Google cloud
platform this is a kind of simplified
way how we in the end architected the
production system but basically whenever
we build a system like this what we're
trying to do is we trying to find you
know what's our integration between our
a I solution with the rest of the world
how do we get the data and how do we get
predictive insight into the customers
hand now tech resource has been
basically managing most of the stuff on
Prem and we've built it in a cloud so as
a result you know of course we've set up
a data ingestion pipeline with them and
actually later on we've introduced a
data later on the data flow was
introduced versus versus how we worked
here with a cloud composer and an error
flow but in the end we basically been
landing data in the cloud storage which
is a very common way of doing that and
then we had a regular job ingesting the
data in a bigquery as well as updating
some of the aggregates in a big table
and the reason we've chose BigTable is
because it's very good for a sparse data
like tens of thousands are columns of
sparse data that we needed and it was
very useful for us to pre create a lot
of different aggregates with a lot of
different averaging windows and a lot of
different parameters so we can then
quickly
sample observations out of them based on
whatever late labeling techniques were
using and sampling different aggregation
windows so we could we could we could
iterate through those very quickly very
quickly without recalculating those
aggregates
every time so that's why we used a big
table for that which is kind of unusual
in a way and you know in the end we've
developed an API that basically sits in
the in the App Engine and behind the
Google Cloud endpoint have a rest
endpoint for them to call so all they
need to do after all of this implemented
is basically I tell me at this point in
time what's your prediction that this
truck will fail or give me predictions
for all 108 trucks
today or out of five days ago right
that's basically the API that we gave
them the API behind-the-scene calculated
several made several predictions apply
the smoothing that we need and threw
back up the probability as well as
whether it's a lot conditions or not
based on a selected threshold right and
you know API basically picked the fixed
data from fixed features from BigTable
which are updated as part of the data
ingestion it picks the model from the
cloud storage bucket so that we can
update model without you know impacting
and restarting our applications and
presents the result as a JSON in the
response right so it's not that
complicated so all they need to do is
that regularly call it regular call it
and get the results in front of users or
store them in their own systems and it's
very important that you could embed it
in their own systems other than give
them something new because I said hell
supervisor I already have a lot of
things and dashboards to look at they
don't need yet another thing right
although it may be somewhat ugly ish you
can argue it's really in front of the
users and what they using now and that's
very important and when we build the
systems with an API that's exposing an
API that allows us this ease of
embedding ease of integration like as
opposed to have very tight you know
they're very very tight integration and
you know as you build it on Google Cloud
we have all the operational metrics in a
stack driver and have a dashboard that's
showing us exactly
going on how much sources used how many
predictions are being made and etc etc
so very kind of sleek and very easy to
use and it's been running basically on
its own with one failure in a about a
year and a half I think right so
something got full somewhere and and and
it was that way that way it felt it
wasn't monitor before now let's look at
a specific example what you know one of
the failures how it was predicted so
this isn't they called Aida triggered a
warning on Thursday morning the acetal
supervisors made a decision in whatever
way they made that seems like it's
legitimate let's take for maintenance it
took for maintenance
they found this contactor rp1 contactors
that been failing replaced it but this
is the the predictive model still was
reporting a pending failure so decided
to take it back for maintenance and then
found another crack in the critical
component that normally results in a
high voltage system failure right
basically electrical cabinet blow-up is
and they blow up in a spectacular way so
you know and it's expensive and that's
what they were able to fix that and then
the model are kind of then dropped down
it prediction to a normal level over
time and it's interesting even though we
trained it on a certain on a certain
range it turns out that the model was
often predicting it a little bit before
that range so having this uncertainty
window helped us a lot when we are kind
of in the middle right it may give a
much more much stronger much more
differentiated signal for the model to
train on right which is very important
for us because we have very few very few
samples right thousands of samples it's
very very little there are little so
what we focus on we focus on quality of
our labels we also would like to have a
good quality of the features but you
know to some degree model can deal with
that noise that's the job of machine
learning model in order to deal with
that noise right of course we want to
reduce that complexity but our focus is
always quality of labels right
this is a something that's kind of cool
that they told us you know four months
after what happened and I read it
because I think it's amazing amazing
results so the work we did with the
Komatsu nine-30 a whole truck sleep has
saved us half a million so far so we put
it in place in April of last year and
that was June of this year and it has so
far prolific six electrical cabinet blow
ups so the model producer predicted six
now four of these were actioned acid
health supervisor took a decision yep
good idea two of them were not action as
it held supervisor so that the model
doesn't know what it's doing and they
missed it it's caused the failure
now one cabinet blow-up was missed so
the model didn't react predicted weather
because we choose tress fault a little
too high intentionally or because there
was just a failure that was so rapidly
developing that there was no pattern for
it right it's possible to so on they
estimated that it was three to four
million dollar per annum that they would
say from this use case alone per year so
it's incredible incredible ROI that we
that we are able to achieve and call our
this CI your yesterday evening told me
you know you know how much we save this
year alone with this on a 10 truck
failures that they successfully
predicted and avoided they saved the 4
million this year alone so it's actually
tuned up even better than they than they
thought before the result was even
better so that was the maintenance our
predictive maintenance use case again
working with a structured data
structured data are very few events
interested events and kind of a creating
way how we frame this problem as a
machine learning problem right so now we
want to move to a cricket game analysis
which is pretty cool we work with the
English and Wales Cricket Board and it's
basically a single national governing
body for all cricket games in England
and Wales that includes you know the top
league games as well as you know college
games and all you know every single in
between every single between so one of
their tedious jobs that their staff is
doing is that the analysts need to watch
an average of cricket video in order to
capture extract information from the
games what happens when the ball is
delivered what type of shot it is you
know and so on and all the
characteristics right so it takes it
very a long time it's a very manual work
so why don't we try to create a system
that will either simplify that are all
basically just analyze and extract all
those all those events right so manual
analysis of this doesn't quite scale
they usually analyze only the top tier
events and the rest they don't because
they have just not I mean it's not
affordable to invest those efforts in
this right and another problem is that
they have a group of people and they all
kind inconsistent they all kind of few
seconds apart sometimes they make a
mistake and so on so they actually not
very active system in analyzing the
games right now where do we start you
know just like I skipped that from the
attack story but normally when you come
in the beginning will try to make an
initial discovery an assessment what are
the rounds of possible within the domain
you are looking at what are the
potential use cases and you basically
build a mini kind of risk reward matrix
we look at the feasibility and risks of
solving a specific use case as a machine
learning with the machine learning and
then you know we look at the potential
value and we calculate certain weighted
number and that gives us an input to an
executive and a senior leadership which
of those we need to focus on soft so not
very difficult to interpret it's very
powerful it's very powerful and it
turned out that ball separation use
cases basically was the most fundamental
and the reason as the most fundamental
the most important is that before
basically everything else needs to be
done
analysts need to look through those
hours and hours of footage and you know
a game over the five days it's about
eight hours of game normally right like
this is a first class you know a test
game international game and there's the
hours of video but most of the time is
idle as people do nothing like the ten
seconds basically both deliver in a 10
seconds few seconds play that people
really interested in right so extracting
those out of all those hours will remove
a huge amount of overhead right away
right so that what we wanted to focus on
first and there was a number of ways how
we could do how we could do that right
so let's look at the data that we're
working with right so we kind of know
the need in some way right so here's our
big data begin as we look at this right
it's a terabyte of unstructured video
data right there's a tens of thousands
of hours of HD video or standard video
depending on the game being captured and
you know a five days of footage you know
up to 40 hours usually kind of in 20s is
about you know 100 to 200 gigabytes
worth of data right so it's quite a bit
to work with right and you know other
than the normal footage there's also
like a Hawkeye footage available which
is a special cameras it you know some of
the stadium's equipped that's you know
tracking the ball tracking the ball so
it's pretty impressive what they do but
we've been mostly working with just the
footage now the footage can be added
televised or non-televised non-televised
footage is done by a cameras installed
by analysts somewhere in a static
location and that's it and the televised
footage is what you see on the TV right
which is cool it has commentary it has
overlays so as a result we have some
additional input other than what's
happening in the game itself we have a
data from the overlay that we could
possibly use and we have an audio data
which we could also possible use and you
will see how ladies we've actually
helped us a lot
kotas a lot right but basically what
happens is that as a cricket game is
played he's the bowler that's running
let's call it run up so he runs with the
ball then he finishes and those I'm
demonstrating really bad for those of
you who who know who know cricket right
I see you smile but that boy they
release the ball and then the bathrooms
here was a wizard wizard with a bad like
bang hits or misses right but that's
really a very unique moment in the game
that we want to spot it's a very unique
position of players they make very
unique movements and pretty much all
televised footages have a very specific
seen how they film it from behind as
bowler running like this right so
obviously there must be a way to you
know to spot those to spot those
patterns right
okay so now what we have looked at in
the very beginning
or we could looking at our beginning is
you know use some of the pre train model
as you're working with Google cloud
there's a quite a few train models
available we looked at their cloud with
your intelligence API you know it has
ability to detect scene change so we can
use that as input in our model to see
when the shot is changing so it moves
from one to another which is potentially
could help us before this ball deliverer
happens as well some annotations turned
out they're not very useful for us
because it basically been always
attempting players like a cricket game
or some other ball game and so on like a
stadium and a lot of things but not
quite useful for what we need right the
cloud vision API
you know also can annotate what it sees
on the frame right and it also has an
ocean component an ocean component could
allow us to look at those overlays and
see when this overlay changes because
overlay changes after the ball delivery
happens right so that's an interesting
thing to know and they could use
speech-to-text API in order to parse
comentary and apply maybe some enoki to
it we ended up not doing that but there
was another new that was available to us
right now again remember that we want to
present and state the problem as a
supervised learning problem right so
it's it's very important if you always
narrow down into this so here's the data
that analysts extract like a sub sub
shot of it right for each delivery
there's a line and it has the
information of you know okay who is a
batsman and a bowler what type of shot
it is you know a wicket type and the
timestamp as well you know where the
ball landed like and so on right so
that's what manual tedious work right
unfortunately we could not use this data
reliably simply because the time step
that they had could not be matched to
offsets in the video in a continuous
video because this continuous video
first of all it doesn't have a concept
of a timestamp and it's also sometimes
fast forwarded and so on so there was no
easy way in order to match those to the
locations in video plus they were not
very precise it's always by a few
seconds of right and we really need to
be focusing on those specific seconds of
the video right so there was a problem
now if we're going further I want to
kind of review what we need to solve and
how we map it to how we can map it to a
machine learning problem so what we need
is we need to take this long footage cut
it into small bits right basically that
means we'll need offsets in a video that
will indicate where the ball delivery
happens within a few seconds
precision and then from there on we can
just cut about you know even like 10
seconds frames which is 10 seconds
fragment which is you know this is
usually long enough for the game to be
over so we could also try to train the
model 2 to find out when the ball
whether the play finished but you know
we didn't really need to do that we
needed to focus on the very on a very
beginning right so the way that we can
kind of stir it as a machine learning
problem is that we basically need to to
look at the other individual frames or a
sequence of frames that's what the video
is and then predict whether it looks
like this time in the beginning of a
ball delivery or not it's quite specific
again compared to the rest of the arrest
of the recording the rest of the footage
right so it must be doable right but
that's basically how we stated this
problem right so it's a classification
problem we can potentially do it
multi-label classification by you know
having you know but by predicting what
it looks like the bowler is actually
just doing a run up before the before
the release whether it's actually the
ball was released and traveling in the
air towards the batsman but we didn't
need it to be that complicated we just
did it binary you know whether it's
within this range or not right so as a
frame or a sequence as I said right now
the bonus things available is that hey
we can also look in some heuristics from
data trackers from overlays as well as
use some text processing over the
commentary if we really have to you know
one of those things we actually ended up
using so when we worked with that last
last summer we've just built a very
quick auto ml vision prototype when
alternate vision was still in alpha and
it worked really well for us so it told
us that
it told us that it's very feasible to
actually implement a proper system
around this what we've done is we just
created a few thousands extracting a few
thousands of frames and we labeled them
as either a ball event or a non
Bullivant which is everything else that
looks different right and from that
alone the outer male model was able to
achieve quite a good performance and
precision recall was basically around
you know 95% for that right so very
quickly very quickly we could we could
you know build the model even just on
the frames themselves right when the
frames themselves now there's a replace
there's some highlights or sometimes it
will make a fellow's false positives
there's other ways to handle it but it
gives us a good confidence okay it's
possible to do right did some just a
very quick manual labeling now so we've
done it what we've done it in order to
make it much more robust is that we
needed more labels the good thing is
that these days there's a lot of ways to
actually label images and label our
videos right so and there's many
services you can use like a crowdsource
those are specialists now instead of
doing that we've basically built a very
simple interface in order to label the
videos and use some of the you know
research students that we crowdsource to
to do that for us to help us now but
what we've also done is a very
interesting thing is that we reduced
labeling efforts by using a few
techniques that allows us to
approximately say we're in a video there
gonna be a ball delivery and what we use
is two things is two things one of those
was a using cloud vision API OCR that
you know detected where they're overlaid
changes and we've basically built some
heuristic around this that all say this
seems like a ball delivery right so that
was pretty pretty good but it was always
late by some second 10 15 20 because it
happens later and depending on a
broadcaster you know it's different
overlays different and the time shift is
different other things we used is that
we use the combination of unsupervised
learning clustering and basically a
transfer learning so what we've done is
that and it's great thing and use those
systems available on our ecosystem but
what we took
that we took an inception a 3d model
that was trained on the kinetics data
set and it's about 500,000 videos if I
remember with various human actions
labeled in them and that model was
trained on there it takes an input as a
frame sequence right and it produces an
output which is basically a multi label
classifier right but what we've done
with it is that we stripped the last
layers out of this model and then we
ended up with a fragment that basically
producing a 600 numeric representation
like a $600 vector right for each
sequence that it's fed with so if you
can think of it in a way of that we took
a video sequence which is you know
hundreds by hundreds of for each frame
and we looked at two seconds sequences
so it's you know 50 frames so it's tens
of thousands of numbers times three for
RGB channels right so we took this and
narrowed it down to 600 in such a way
that it came from a model that was
trained to recognize certain human
motions as opposed to in any other
random we're using some dimensionality
reduction technique or whatnot right so
what you've done after that is that
basically run a simple k-means
clustering and it became quite obvious
that was in this video fragment that
close to ball delivery there were
certain clusters are showing up very
quickly right so we use this clustering
technique and basically say hey if the
video sequence is in this cluster
it means it's close to ball delivery
it's actually worked reasonably well to
give us a general idea where we are
right so again I'm quite an interesting
interesting trick and using this model
was super easy actually it's available
on the tensor flow hub so we basically
just load it and then you know modify it
to to our needs right oh it's actually
available in a github as well and it's a
the model was done by the Google's you
know research AI research arm deep line
tour alphabets
I guess on the resource man deep mind so
talented team and they produce a lot of
things and open source so what we've
done is that we've
how we're doing on time well
what we've done with it is that we took
those approximate locations right here
on the sides you see and we create a
small HTML page with you know basically
a single page with some JavaScript
embedded in it in order to allow us to
you know move second by second frame by
frame and very quickly mark tag places
in the video as a certain event on the
certain tags right we actually we're
actually just going to open source it as
available page so we could everybody
could use it but basically we end up
with those tags so we went through the
dozens and dozens of those long-form
footage producers produced few thousands
of those of those labels and that
basically split our time of a footage
into a place where certain elements of a
game happened and specifically the the
time when this bowler running up and
it's throwing the ball and the ball hit
by a batsman that's the thing that we
focused on and basically made it made a
binary classifier out of it again right
and what we've done with this is that we
trained two models one of them is that
we basically took that kinetics data set
based a 3d model which producing 600
actors and we use those 600 of the input
features into a simple classifier I mean
we could have just you know stripped
additional layer on top of it and make
it not you know freeze training of that
bit but in the end you know in any way
you do it we again used a transfer
learning right because the model already
trained on this and we turn it into the
classification problem as opposed to
kind of semi useable clustering right
and we achieved very high precision and
recall pretty quickly on this and a high
very high 90s and we also build a frame
classifier I mean we could have arguably
takes a bit the same approach by by
possibly taking a pre-existing image you
know classification algorithm pick
important layers from it and then
retrain is for what we need right
fortunately this product already exists
and it's called Google Cloud ultramel
vision because it's exactly what it is
right so it's already pre trained on a
lot of the photos
and our we just need to additionally
train it on the frames that we need
right so and we basically merged those
models together and made the decision
and build a small micro service API
micro service API we because it takes a
long time you know to go through several
hours of HD video and undo it and
extract frames and apply these models it
needs to be asynchronous but again we
were always thinking of as an as an API
that can be embedded in other systems
right so their API here is that sending
a message in a pub subtopic that gives
us location of the video in their cloud
our cloud storage right there there's a
kubernetes cluster that runs workers at
auto scales based on the number of
messages in a queue that picks up that
video goes through that with OpenCV
extract the frames and feed those frames
as into the kinetics based model and as
well as send some of the frames into the
Google ultramel vision and then stitches
quote-unquote those two together
basically build a simple and simple out
of those and creates a a JSON file that
it's puts in another cloud pub/sub topic
so how this this is embedded is that we
send the message when the video is
available or we can automatically send
the message in the pub sub Q and video
is uploaded for example as many ways we
can we can do it in a Google cloud
platform and then we just wait on a
queue for the processing to finish and
we do whatever we need to do in the
beginning we just created a small you
eyes that will basically in a similar
fashion that I show you as a labeling it
would kind of show us the label so this
could go through it and evaluate you
know how well it's working
how about what's working but another
another not shown here is that component
that basically takes the video picks the
JSON from a pops up when the labels
become available and basically cuts the
images in a small in a small bits rights
very very easy to do so we have a full
pipeline by taking
long-form video and transforming it in a
short form and it works pretty pretty
sleek so when I was preparing for it I
was saying it would be really cool that
Google introduced Auto ml video because
it just made sense cuz we would just do
it in exactly the same way right just
what this morning it was announced that
you know ultramel video intelligence is
basically the same thing as vision Otomo
right but works on the sequence of video
right in exactly the same way so what we
could have done if it was available
earlier and instead of used that now
maybe would work good enough on the
videos that focused on people's movement
maybe not right it still remain to be
seen because kinetics is one that been
focused on predicting the the people
movement right what people do in their
actions right so it's this domain
transfer worked really well for us the
transfer link work really well for us
but maybe maybe it's too generic right
but we will definitely try it and I'm
pretty sure would get some good initial
results right so it's greater than we
have availability of those even if we
don't end up using them 100% at the end
it will already give us a very quick
idea if it's possible or not and we can
you know go to more complicated
solutions as needed
[Music]